>> Joe: MASON APPLETON HAS
POSITION OF THE PARK, AND
CLOSING TTLE BIT MORE
FIREPOWER THAN THEY HAVE
WOULD TARGET.>> HE LETS ROAD T
THE EAST FORMER BRUIN,
AND SCHWARTZ
RAIN, VISITING WHITE ON  THETHE
Craig: THE CRACK AND VERY WELL.
AND HEARY ASSIST, THE FOLLOW
UP BY WILSON AND INTO THE TOCKES
LOVE IT AND
METRO.
AND GETTING THERE AHEAD HAS FOUT
WASHINGTON, THE FORMER SAN L L
PRAYERS AND COMFORTING HUGS, SEE
THE NET, NOT VERY BIG,
COMMOTION BY ESTABLISHING  AND
VITEK VANECEK, WILSON FROM HIS
VITEK VANECEK,  IN THE MIDST OFY
NEVER,>> Joe: AND REAMS DYCHE,
OF THE GO, HATHARATES HIM
FROM
XFINITY MOBILE.  THEM EARLY.
BACKSTROM GUIDES IT
THE POWER PLAY ON FIRE, HERE'SW
IN, CAN,
DANO IS THE CAPITALS.
THE DEFENSEMAN, NO CHANCE FOR
THEM TO CATCH UP FOR CONNOR, HE